today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
you know how i've been using this phrase
this is not a rehearsal
this is the real thing and i've used it
so much in a sense that it's become a
meme
well it's also beautifully accurate to
describe
what it is that is going on right now in
all aspects in the lead up to this
november of 2020 election
our suspicions about the improper
purging of voter rolls
in georgia have been confirmed as we
have now
received news that yes the state of
georgia
removed nearly 200 000
people from the voter rolls by
wrongly concluding that they
either moved and didn't update their
voter registration
or for other reasons no longer needed
to be on the active voter list
this is exactly what we believed was
going on
in georgia this is exactly what we
believe is now going on
in wisconsin pennsylvania notice these
are all important states it's not
happening in idaho
which is going to go to trump for sure
it's not happening in massachusetts
which is going to go to biden for sure
at least not to this degree
the aclu of georgia put out a report
about this
and it has indeed concluded
that this purge was
not proper and it was a way to just pull
people
off of the voter rolls now the georgia
secretary of state
has said that the removals were no such
purge everything is fine this was just
routine maintenance on voting lists and
what they claim they did
was simply remove inactive voters
because this is a provision that the
state has
where on some period some rolling basis
they go through and apply a logic for
what is now an inactive voter now what
deemed someone an inactive voter
if they hadn't voted for uh three years
i'm sorry if they had not voted in two
general elections
and haven't had contact with the board
of elections
during that time and if that
situation lasted for at least
three years that is a very low bar
to deem someone as inactive two election
cycles where you might not vote
really is not a sign that you should be
removed from the voter rolls this is
really the wrong conversation because in
many countries this entire concept
of being registered to vote is a lunatic
concept
registered to vote you're a citizen
and you can vote and you don't need any
pre-registration this is not a
restaurant reservation where listen not
everybody goes to eat at a restaurant
so if you want a table you've got to
call ahead this is voting my friends
and about 313 000 voters in total were
removed that's about 4 percent of the
voters in georgia
and um before uh
at at some interim period 22 000
were re-added to the voter rolls through
december of 2021 because of a lawsuit
but again this is just a fraction of the
total voters that are removed now you
might also remember
that brian kemp was secretary of state
of georgia
when this was done and he was also
running for governor
which he ultimately won by only 54 000
votes
against stacey abrams so you don't have
to look too
far to find red flags in this election
the guy
saying we should pull hundreds of
thousands of people off of the voter
rules
not only was the guy running the
election but he was one of the people
running in the election so do not be
surprised when this happens
again across the country in november
and i wish i had some grand solution to
this well we're going to
aclu is going to take aclu is going to
try
other voting groups are going to try
greg palast is working on this issue
but at this point we've got eight weeks
to go we we have
it is september third the election is on
november third that's what 61 days
i think 30 in december i'm sorry 30 in
september
uh gets us to october 3rd and then 31 in
october gets us to november i think it's
61 days
we need to outnumber them in extreme
numbers check if you are registered to
vote
figure out where you vote find out if
there's early voting
figure out how to request an absentee
ballot so we're in the description
to this youtube clip we have resources
at usa.gov for confirming your voter
registration status
with links to how to register if you
have not yet done so
the deadlines in some states are coming
up and then we have
vote.org polling place locator
and absentee ballot request these are
central websites usa.gov and vote.org
which will direct you to how to obtain
the information you need
in your particular state they're doing
it
it's been confirmed that they've been
doing it they are going to do it
and later today this is unbelievable
donald trump has now suggested that
voters commit the felony
of willingly trying to vote twice to
test the system
i'll talk to you about that later but
chaos is the word that summarizes all of
this
there is a very interesting new poll
from fox news
that shows trump losing just about
everything and republicans losing a
whole bunch of stuff in november now
normal caveats
one poll doesn't tell us anything we
don't go by the polls we go by votes
which is why no matter what the polls
say you go and vote
um fox news polling is not the same as
tucker carlson right fox news polling is
actually uh
quite well rated and the actual field
work for fox news polling is done by
other companies that are hired by fox
news so
fox news polling is relatively good okay
what does this poll
say well first of all incumbent
republican senators
are losing significantly
in arizona and north carolina donald
trump
is losing nationally and in some key
battleground states but let's
let's be thorough here first of all is
the methodology of this fox news poll
solid
it is uh it's very popular to say
who's picking up landlines these days
these polls only
they're only talking to landlines wrong
this is a poll mostly of cell phones
with some landlines it distinguishes
between their overall sample and the
fine-tuned likely voter model
which has a 3.5 point margin of error
that's
normal and to be expected so the
methodology is good
on trump versus biden among likely
voters
joe biden is up 9 49 to 40. among
registered voters joe biden is up 10 49
to 39 so
that's very close the fact that it's not
a that it's not a big difference between
registered voters and likely voters
suggests that the people who are
actually planning to vote
are roughly representative of all adults
who are registered
to vote now on the issues donald trump
in this poll is still winning on the
economy but just barely
barely in some polls trump is now losing
on the economy
in this one he's winning but only by one
45 to 44
and he's losing on every other major
issue trump is losing by one to biden on
who would better deal with china
trump is losing by five to biden on who
would better handle policing and
criminal justice
and on coronavirus which is in poll
after poll
the issue for voters donald trump is
trailing joe biden by
17. let's now look at those senate
numbers because as many of you are
emailing me
correctly assessing almost as important
at changing the figurehead at the top
meaning the president
is looking at taking the senate from
republicans so they can stop putting in
judges
so that they can stop obstructing
sensible reforms to so many aspects
of our economy and our society and our
country so
there's a few really good senate numbers
for democrats in
arizona we've got senator i'm sorry
democratic challenger mark kelly
up against incumbent senator martha
mcsally mark
kelly is leading by 17
among likely voters 56 to 39
just one poll you want to take an
average of polls
to get a more precise assessment but
plus 17 is a shocking number
in a state that was a red state for
a long time now the numbers for north
carolina senate are from a different fox
news poll also released yesterday the
democratic challenger
there is cal cunningham leading the
incumbent republican senator tom tillis
by 6
48 to 42 now that's still going to be an
uphill battle the challenger being below
50
means that when you have 10 percent of
the electorate saying
i'm either undecided or third party
often
they will coalesce around the incumbent
so that
we have to fight that one but it is a
great sign
just two months out in north carolina
and then
stunning numbers from wisconsin where
donald trump is now down by
eight in this poll 50 to 42
remember that in 2016 in wisconsin it
was less than one point
separating donald trump and hillary
clinton i think it was about
0.70.8 donald trump of course ultimately
winning
in wisconsin and that was one of the
places where monday morning
quarterbacking the election we heard
frequently
hillary didn't go she didn't even go to
wisconsin fair criticism at the time
among others we will see uh joe biden in
wisconsin i believe today
if not tomorrow so what do we do
in light of these numbers you know the
answer we vote
that's it if you go and look at the 538
projection for 2020
it still says ominously that
70 chance of a biden win and
29 chance of a trump win are the current
numbers
those are the same numbers that hillary
versus trump had in this projection
in 2016 it means either person could win
and it means every vote needs to be cast
and it means you need a plan for how to
vote again we have resources that we
have been posting
on usa.gov and vote.org
figure out if you are registered what is
your polling place
is there early voting how do you
register for an absentee ballot how do
you track the status
of your absentee ballot have a plan we
can't take anything for granted but this
one fox news poll and again the senate
we're really looking at that senate
where democrats need to pick up
a few seats and if we lose the alabama
seat the doug jones seat
that'll be one extra seat that needs to
be picked up to take control
there is a path there is a path to
democrats taking the senate
and if democrats were to take the senate
keep the house and defeat donald trump
it would be one of the
biggest uh uh defeats
for the republican party in history
making a president a one-term president
is tough bill clinton did it to george
h.w bush
but it is not super common the power of
incumbency
is called the power because it is
powerful
uh we've got a lot to do we've got a lot
to work on phone banking get out the
vote
so on and so forth we'll be here with
you uh through
and beyond the election make sure you're
getting the daily audio podcast
carry it around with you in your pocket
on
any one of your favorite podcasting apps
be it itunes
spotify stitcher pandora
google play and let me know what you're
seeing in your state
on twitter where you can find me at deep
hackman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one
sitting that's exactly what one of my
favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in
15 minutes blinkist makes sure that
you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
there are some really interesting posts
on the david pakman show
subreddit that i wanted to call your
attention to this morning of course you
can join the discussion at
davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t we now have a nearly 23
000 if you can imagine it i remember
when the subreddit was
uh teeny tiny we now have almost 23
000 of our viewers and listeners
participating there find it
davidpakman.com reddit a user
named texasmickey posted
call me an optimist but i think david is
wrong about the number of trumpists in
the country
i've heard him say that even if biden
wins
this country will still need to grapple
with 60 million trumpists who voted for
him
i won't dispute that trumpus will be a
problem for this country long after
trump is out of office however
i don't believe that even most
republican voters are
trumpists i think we underestimate the
number of people who just vote for
whoever has a big
r next to their name and the ballot and
move on with their lives they're not die
hards
they're loyal voters who don't really
care about policy they couldn't tell you
what trump has done well or poorly they
couldn't tell you how biden differs from
trump in any meaningful way
they just vote the party line every four
years
i'm not saying the trumpest ideology
isn't something to be taken as a serious
threat
i only mean that i think it's a smaller
sect within the party
well you know the oftentimes when we
talk about
radical islam you will hear these
sort of um concentric circles
of nominal the nominal muslim world
which is a billion people
and then within that these subsequently
smaller and smaller groups and you could
do this for any population you could do
it with
christian extremists you could do it
with jewish extremists these smaller and
smaller circles
you're right that if you start with 65
million people who
might vote for donald trump in november
not all
65 are the problematic radical trumpists
that's for sure
but certainly the 65 million are people
who decided to go along with it
regardless and that's bad enough
in a lot of ways you can then look at
smaller numbers so of the 65 million
you have some portion who almost voted
for biden but went with the republican
because of their historically republican
they might be the least defensive of the
group
then you've got people who actually like
what donald trump presents
in terms of what he uh uh says he will
do policy-wise but also more his idea of
constantly trying to trigger the left
and you like that that might be
you know 80 and then you've got these
concentric circles that's true
the problem is that
when we think about the future of the
country
it is worse if you are a die-hard
trumpist
than just a lifelong republic republican
who checks the box for republicans
that's true
but it's still a total of 65 million
people
who voted for it and if given the
opportunity might vote for it again so
while you're right that 65 million is
not
the number of you know the crazy people
with the guns that we're seeing at
protests
that's true 65 million is still the
number of people who if given the
opportunity would probably do it again
and that's why it's extraordinarily
dangerous another post
from a user on the subreddit posted
an article about doctors who are alarmed
that the usfda is floating emergency use
of a coronavirus vaccine potentially
bypassing some of the trials
i predicted that this was going to
happen i told you guys months ago that
it was going to happen i wasn't the only
person saying it
it's not a pat on the back it's that it
was so obvious that this was going to
happen and yes
even people who are in favor of vaccines
are writing to me worried that using
emergency use authorization mechanisms
to push a vaccine out for likely
political benefit by donald trump
is something we should be concerned
about and that's what i'm going to talk
about next i'm glad that it's on
people's radars
remember you can join the discussion on
the subreddit at davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t all right guys
he's doing it he is doing it donald
trump
and his cdc have sent out a letter to
states
saying be ready to start
distributing a coronavirus vaccine in
early november
or late october we can read that as
before election day okay
do not mistake this for anything other
than what it is
this is exactly what i predicted was
what going to happen i told you
months ago the ideal october surprise
for donald trump is going to be the big
heroic announcement of a coronavirus
vaccine
even if it's not actually done being
tested yet even if it won't
actually be available to almost anybody
until 2021
that is going to be trump's gambit that
is going to be trump's
october surprise to try to win the
election and
indeed as the new york times is
reporting
the cdc has sent a letter outlining to
state public health officials
how they need to prepare for what donald
trump
is saying is going to be a vaccine in
late october
or early november the cdc has notified
all 50 states and five large cities to
be ready to distribute a coronavirus
vaccine to health care workers right
away
subsequently to other people in
high-risk groups as soon as late october
or early november
now over the last week we've heard from
anthony fauci and stephen hahn from the
fda
who said that it is conceivable it is
conceivable that you could make a
vaccine available
before the phase three clinical trials
have been completed
if the early data is overwhelmingly
positive we have the letter from the fda
let's look at it from dr robert redfield
of the cdc
it reads dated the august 27th
dear governors the u.s department of
health and human services and cdc
are rapidly making preparations to
implement large-scale distribution of
covid19 vaccines
in the fall of 2020. this vaccine
distribution program is expected to be a
public health effort of significant
scale
potentially involving hundreds of
millions of vaccine doses to be
distributed across the u.s
cdc has contracted with mckesson to
distribute these vaccines to state and
local health departments
medical facilities doctor offices and
other vaccine providers
in order to accomplish this massive task
mckesson must quickly open
new distribution centers and obtain new
permits and licenses
these applications may be submitted in
mckesson's name or in the name of one of
its subsidiaries going on to say
in the near future the appropriate state
licensing agency will receive
permit applications for the new
distribution
facilities going on to say that
states should consider waiving
requirements
that would prevent these facilities from
being fully operational by november 1st
the requirements you may be asked to
waive in order to expedite vaccine
distribution
will not compromise the safety or
integrity of the products being
distributed
your assistance in helping expedite the
issuance
of licenses and permits required for
this will be
critical to the success of this public
health effort to mitigate the threat
presented
by covid 19.
so why not be more transparent and just
say before november 3rd
because that's really what this is about
now i've gotten a lot of emails from
from viewers saying do you trust the cdc
now with this
i have no idea i have no idea certainly
we
knew this was what they were going to go
for people have been asking me
if they approve a coronavirus vaccine
with an emergency use order on october
29th
do you go and get in line first for that
vaccine
i think that's the wrong question
because i'm not going to be allowed to
be first in line and what i mean by that
is
there are tens of thousands of people
who are receiving the vaccine already
in phase three trials the first
availability is going to go as they are
saying to health care workers and to
at-risk people
older folks etc i don't think there's
any way i get a vaccine in
2020 regardless of an emergency youth
use authorization that being said i
understand
being very suspicious about the timing
of this announcement
because i told you it was going to
happen and now they are planning to do
it
here's why we should be skeptical
or worried about distributing a vaccine
with emergency use authorization first
of all
it's never been done before with a
vaccine or at least a major vaccine
that presumably billions of people are
going to want we've done
emergency use authorizations on
technicalities and we've done emergency
use authorizations on things like
hydroxychloroquine room desevere
convalescent plasma now how well did the
hydroxychloroquine
emergency use authorization go not well
at all
and in fact it had to be retracted so
that is because
emergency euas as they are called
involve
substandard or lesser reviews than for
full
approval are we willing to do that with
a vaccine
i don't know the answer to that but it's
definitely something to be thinking
about you know euas for ventilators
euas for ppe maybe for some treatments
that appear to be particularly
efficacious
okay certainly things to talk about here
i don't know
and this is a white house that has
brutally abused
its ability to push the fda to to put
out their euas
and some of them like for example with
hydroxychloroquine
have been revoked because it was a
disastrous idea
but i am concerned with the political
implications here because donald trump
is thinking
and it may work this is the scary thing
the idea would be
if donald trump can announce a vaccine
on october 25th
and make the case that he had a role
in getting this vaccine out there and by
a role i mean
something other than just bullying the
fda into approving an eua
okay and that that's something he can do
just with raw power
but what i'm saying is donald trump is
going to try to sell americans on the
idea
that we have an approved vaccine again
through an
eua earlier than other countries
thanks to trump and the reality is any
country could skip steps to get a
vaccine approved
the uk could be dosing people right now
if they had just gone in and said to the
about the oxford vaccine candidate let's
just approve it
and then oxford vaccine in the uk would
say we got a vaccine early
we saw what happened in russia with
their haphazard early approval of a
supposed vaccine so the gambit is
more people will fall for trump did it
then we'll be skeptical about the
politicized nature of this early
emergency use authorization i want a
vaccine as badly as anybody but it's got
to be safe it's got to be done right we
have a process
for approving vaccines will it work
will it work to sway even one percent of
the vote in key states
could give the election to donald trump
let me know what you think
we'll be continuing our coverage of this
on the david pakman show
instagram page at david pakman show
while you're there i posted a picture
this morning of my new prepping elements
to my instagram david.pakman i'm ready
for a crisis now i just don't know what
kind
follow me on instagram david.pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com coupon code saves you 40
percent
vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
as sometimes happens usually about once
every two or three months
we had a very unfortunate last-minute
guest
cancellation today and so in order to
not delay the publication of the show
instead of hearing from one guest i'm
going to hear from a few of you
by opening up the phone lines at
617-830-4750
starting today with our caller from the
617
area code caller from 617 what's your
name
where are you calling from
caller from 617 i can hear you opening
or closing some kind of cabinet you are
on live
right now
all right bye-bye to 617 that was the
opportunity and it was a wasted one
that's very unfortunate
let's go next to our caller from the 512
area code who's calling today from 512.
uh hello yeah who's this uh this is
andrew
andrew what's going on um so i just
wanted to know like
like what are you what what do you think
of some of these like republican
uh and conservative like political
commentators
like uh ben shapiro
what do i think of them generally yeah
i mean i i disagree with their politics
and i don't really watch them
uh but is i mean i don't know if there's
something maybe more specific you wanted
me to say
um do you think like so like
i have some friends that are uh like
republican
and they watch their videos and will
debate like
you know certain topics or whatever
and i just feel like uh
some of the things that they're saying
could be dangerous
oh absolutely absolutely yeah no listen
i mean i
i guess i should to be more full it's
not just that i disagree with them
i do think that particularly because
they have
very um sort of
manipulatable followers i do think that
some of the ideas that are perpetuated
i can't say specifically ben shapiro or
one or the other because i don't really
watch enough of these shows
to be able to say who's doing it and
who's not but much like
mike pence's rnc speech was very
dangerous
in how even it was getting republicans
to question
whether we can it's it's like almost
like russia where they're both trying to
get us to question whether we can safely
and accurately do an election
uh many of the ideas espoused on these
right-wing shows are dangerous
some of them we know have actually moved
people to
real world violence and they're i'm not
suggesting that
these shows be illegal i'm not
suggesting censorship
what would be great is if we had a
smarter more educated population that
didn't fall for this stuff in the first
place
okay thank you all right for uh
having me on the show and uh keep up the
good work
thanks andrew i appreciate that very
nice to hear from you
let's go next to our caller from the 917
area code who's calling today from 917.
hey david this is sam hey sam what's
going on
so uh i'm right now i'm 19 years old and
i try to engage with a lot of my friends
and talking about
political activism and stuff but i feel
like that the only thing that they could
talk about
is the instagram stories that they are
reposting
and i can't really have educated
discussions with my friends because all
they do is post
uh stuff on their instagram stories of
just headlines with no real
uh explanation or uh education for that
matter just
words um so i'm having trouble engaging
with my friends and i've actually
suggested your
your youtube channel and i'm just
wondering um like what is the best way
to engage with these instagram activists
in real
change besides posting something on
their instagram stories
so you when you say that they're posting
instagram stories
they're instagram stories related to
news and politics but they're just
basically
regurgitating headlines and not really
diving into the substance it sounds like
you're saying
exactly and are they people who are
aligned with you politically or not
aligned with you politically
yeah uh align with me politically and
and usually people who are posting stuff
for black lives matter for
abide in administration but the way they
do it is
they're just posting uh straight
headlines with no real information or
articles supporting their ideas
so what i would ask in an empathetic way
and so the good thing is
you're not trying to change anyone's
mind here these are already people who
are on your side politically you're just
trying to get them to be better
activists and
so a couple different things one check
out my interviews about political
hobbyism i've done a couple of them
which talks about exactly this issue
which is
following the news and like retweeting
or posting stuff to instagram
it's political hobbyism it's not really
activism so first i would check out
those two interviews to kind of
understand the problem
then i would consider going to them and
saying
what is it you would like people to do
when they see you post these stories
like clearly you're posting it because
you think it's important
and you're posting it because you want
other people to see it what do you
envision
other people should be doing and
whatever it is they imagine
other people should be doing that's
probably what they should be doing
themselves right so if they were to say
well i post it so that other people will
get out there
and be in touch with their elected
officials or run for local office in
order to make change well
you could do that instead of just
posting to instagram right so i would i
would let
them tell you what it what action they
think would be most useful
and then challenge them to go and do it
themselves
all right thank you so much david all
right sam
thank you appreciate the phone call
let's go next
to our caller from the 404
area code who's calling today from 404.
404 it seems like you may have us muted
hi david yes
yes yo you can hear me i can who's this
oh this is connor how are you sir connor
pleasure to hear from you
okay uh ditto um so i want to ask david
uh
i have a quick question then i have an
opinion i want to hear your thoughts on
okay uh the first quick question um i
i've seen you on a couple
um shows uh say uh jessie lee peterson's
um well really that's the only one
really and i i i did
watch a little bit of when you were on
joe rogan but um
i've heard you say that you're not a
democrat
and that you're i know you're i know
you're not a conservative but i've heard
you say you're not a democrat but you i
know you
uh most uh for the most part you usually
use the word progressive
what would you definitively state
yourself as
so conor i want to make sure i'll answer
but
i you're not conflating political party
and political ideology right because
when you say conservative or democrat
democrat is a political party
conservative is an ideology so i want to
make sure we're not
it's i want to make sure you're not
confused about what you're asking
i'm sorry yeah i know um republican or
democrat conservative i shouldn't have
used conservatives
okay um so so here's the deal i am not a
democrat because
for me the democratic party is
another institution that i don't find it
particularly useful
to associate with in any formal way or
to pledge any kind of loyalty
or whatever it's never been clear to me
why i would register as a democrat
in modern politics my views of social
democracy which is how i identify
are more represented
candidates in the democratic party than
candidates in the republican party
but that could change and so the way i
characterize my views is i am a
progressive social democrat in practice
i'm mostly voting for democratic
candidates
but i've never found any particular in
massachusetts i can still vote in
whichever primary
i want i've never lost anything by not
being a registered democrat and i just
don't feel particularly drawn to be one
okay amazing um i uh i'm just curious
because i i've never heard you
at least from what i've seen from you
i've never heard you state definitively
what you are
um i would consider myself i would say
i'm more in the middle probably
um i try to be as open-minded as
possible listen to
all sides and all spectrums but um
anyways
uh my opinion i want to get to so i am
biracial i'm also 19 so it's going to be
the first
year which i can vote and i don't know
how i don't know how much you talk about
on your show i don't know how much talk
about race relations but um
being biracial i am black and white uh
growing up in the south
i'm from uh atlanta georgia i
went to predominantly black schools um
for the most part
i went to a predominantly black middle
school predominantly back high school
and i'm taking college courses online so
it's not really um
i don't really go anywhere and see
people but um
i want to ask i just want your opinion
on it because growing up
in these areas that are predominantly
black um
i've been treated certain ways and a lot
of people call it colorism
um i've been treating treated certain
ways because i am
lighter skinned uh some people look at
me they're like oh you're black or oh
you're
white or oh you're hispanic um it never
offends me i just you know i get i'm a
little
ambiguous looking uh but it's uh um i've
noticed that i've been treating
i've been treated a certain way by uh
a lot of um african-americans
in this in the area i live in i've been
uh i've been
called a white boy which isn't really a
derogatory term but i've been called
white boy
i've been called cracker i've been
assumed because i don't
because i don't align myself with a lot
of political parties i've been assumed
to be
a nazi or a uh
a white supremacist um things like that
and it was just it's so silly and
i don't really call it ignorance and the
reason why i don't call it ignorance
this is one thing i actually kind of
agree with jesse lee peterson on because
he told me he said it
it's not really ignorance it's more so
that's how they're being brought up
and that's what they're being taught to
believe right is
um um by their parents or whoever you
know whatever talking head
you know that might uh spew the type of
things that they believe in but um
i just noticed that it's it's very
common you know
and and it's it's proof that it ha it
doesn't only have anything to do with
just me going to school
because i've experienced it at work i've
experienced that
i've experienced it outside of work like
you know in social
settings and things like that and uh
i've had people
countless times try to diminish
my experience say oh you wouldn't
understand what it's like being black or
you wouldn't like all that other
nonsense i just i feel like it's kind of
ridiculous because i don't really think
that the reason why
black keeps there are black people who
dream like that i don't think it has
anything to do with
say systemic racism or because we're
holding them down i just think it has to
do with the
the um immorality or the just the lack
of respect for other people
so i kind of want your take on that yeah
i mean i i
tend to agree with you now my experience
with this obviously
is not personal it's more academic and
through talking to others but
colorism is prevalent all over the world
in different ways in different places
i would defer to you if you're telling
me that
you don't identify that that's happening
because of reasons a and b
and it's happening because of reason c
and d i think your experience
in in that is important and it certainly
passes the sniff test for me it
sounds plausible that the reason you are
called
what you're called because you don't
look as black as some of the people
around you
i don't think that that is directly
because of systemic racism
and and i i i think your assessment on
it is way better than any
any i could give
okay well i appreciate that david all
right i appreciate the call thank you so
much great to hear from you glad
we were able to take a few phone calls
we turned a bad situation
a call a uh guest cancelling last minute
into a good situation because i was able
to hear from a few of you
we will go to a break and have much more
right after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about
them
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
if you ask me which president has most
weaponized their attorney general
i immediately think of donald trump and
william barr william barr has been a
hatchet man for donald trump interfering
in the mueller investigation
putting out that insane propaganda
letter pretending as though the mueller
report was going to completely exonerate
donald trump despite specifically saying
that it can't do that
william barr has been a player
with respect to the protests that we've
been seeing and
seeing and the use of force against
protesters and william barr yesterday
was interviewed by cnn's wolf blitzer
and it is a veritable house of horrors
this is one of the sickest interviews
i've seen and what's sick about it is
that
william barr sometimes there are
propaganda mouthpieces
who know that they need to sort of put a
nice coat of paint
on their propaganda right they need to
dress it up
they need to make it sparkle william
barr is not even pretending to care
about the brazen and disgusting nature
of how he is just going to get behind
any crazy notion donald trump brings up
about protesters or about vote by mail
or whatever else so let's get right into
it you've got to see this this is
unbelievable
barr was asked by wolf blitzer
uh what trump has let me let me back up
i'm getting ah i'm shot out of a cannon
i'm getting ahead of myself
donald trump has talked about the
problem with mail-in ballots is a
foreign country could print off millions
of them
and submit them and um
there's of course no evidence of that so
wolf blitzer
rightly asks william barr what evidence
do you have that said
that's something foreign countries could
do and william barr
simply says logic the answer is logic
and wolf blitzer is visibly taken aback
by how stupid this argument is
and basically as i've said repeatedly
i'm basing that on logic
pardon logic
but have you seen any evidence that a
foreign country is trying to interfere
with exactly no i'm saying people are
concerned about foreign influence and if
we use a ballot system
with the the system that some you know
that states are just now and trying to
adopt
it does leave open the possibility of
counterfeiting
ballots either by someone here or so you
think a foreign country could do that i
think anyone could do it have you seen
any evidence that they're trying to do
that no but most things can be
counterfeited that's why we go to the
trouble of
you know count of uh making our money
the way we make it
now you know should we have minnesota
print up our money on on you know
regular parchment paper
so this yeah this is this is the same
thing mark meadows
said to jake tapper trump's current
chief of staff
he said i haven't seen evidence that
it's
not going on which is of course one of
these completely indefeasible arguments
that
it doesn't really fall under actual
argumentation
because it's completely indefeasible
it's mumbo jumbo
nonsense to be perfectly frank now then
wolf blitzer asks this this i haven't
seen a wolf blitzer of you for a long
time but he did a good job of really
getting down to the heart of the matter
on a lot of these issues wolf blitzer
asks of the three countries
china russia and iran which are kind of
the three that are thrown around as
having an interest in meddling in the
election not necessarily
in in you know in favor of the same
person
but the evidence that china and iran are
interfering is of course
far less prevalent than that of russia
and maybe you're not going to be
surprised at which one
william barr selects here russia china
and iran
are seeking to interfere in the u.s
presidential election for various
reasons but mostly
they want to sow dissent in our country
exacerbate
racial tensions etc like that of those
three countries that the intelligence
community has pointed to
russia china and iran which is the most
assertive the most aggressive in this
area
i believe it's china which one china
china more than russia right now yes why
do you say that because i've seen the
intelligence that's what i've concluded
what are they trying to do
i'm not going to discuss that to this
but they're trying to help
who who i'm not going to get into that
more aggressive than russia
yes because uh us intelligence community
trying to influence the united states
yes yeah
super convincing right i mean there this
is a real opportunity to talk more
generally about interference
and meddling and they could actually
have had a conversation about
listen there's a long history of other
countries
meddling in the elections of other
countries there's a long history
of americans trying to exert our
preferences at the high government level
on the elections of other countries
and this is sort of an ongoing thing and
what matters is
we protect our system from any meddling
the problem with making that case for
people like william barr
is that william barr and mitch mcconnell
and donald trump they've all had
opportunities to strengthen our election
system
so that it is less uh subject to the
manipulations of foreign countries
they've not done it and and of course
the speculation is
they've not done it because they think
that on balance the meddling
including from russia is good for donald
trump that's the reality
instead bar just says oh
china is really the worst one and it
makes it sort of an adjudication of
china versus russia the implication of
course being
that china wants biden to win which is
really a question mark but it's
something that's been been repeated
whereas russia wants trump to win the
reason
that there's a sort of base rape fallacy
with these ideas that
if x country wants biden to win it's
because biden will be in their pocket
the reality is that most countries
sorry most countries have an interest
in the more stable united states
so china may well want joe biden to be
president instead of trump because trump
is an unstable maniac
iran may well want biden instead of
trump
because biden maybe would stick to his
word instead of how donald trump just
bailed
on the iran deal despite iran not having
done anything wrong so
just because a country prefers one
candidate over another doesn't mean
that they're they have that preference
for nefarious reasons
russia specifically we know because it's
in black and white and it's been in
black and white for decades
their goal to seize and grow
their power globally is
to make western democracies appear
unstable
and that's why they would support donald
trump so there's a real
apples to spark plugs comparison going
on here now
wolf blitzer getting back to how many
indictments have there been for voter
fraud if voter fraud
really is the problem you claim it is
how many indictments have there been
uh william barr tells us several 10
years attorney general of the united
states how many indictments
have you brought against people
committing voter fraud
i couldn't tell you off the top of my
head but several
i know like a handful i i can't i don't
know
but several doesn't sound like too many
well i don't know i don't know how many
we have
i know there are a number of
investigations right now some very big
ones in states
the president also has said and i'm
quoting him directly
and wolf blitzer is right in a country
of 331 million
with billions of votes cast over the
last however many election cycles
uh several cases of voter fraud
really isn't a lot it's not hundreds
it's not thousands
it's not anything that comes even close
to impacting
the election results and then william
barr
insists we simply haven't tried mail in
voting so
it's a question mark it's a black hole
anything could happen
we haven't seen widespread fraud but so
far we haven't tried it well and
the point is that a lot of us there are
several states that only have
mail-in voting including a republican
this is playing with fire
this is playing with fire we're very
closely divided country here
and if people have to have confidence in
the results of the election and the
legitimacy of the government
and people trying to change the rules to
this to this methodology which
as a matter of logic is very open to
fraud and coercion
is reckless and dangerous and people are
playing with fire well
i will point out there are five states
that only have mainland voting
including utah and colorado washington
state oregon
uh hawaii and they they've reported over
the years they've had virtually
no problems but who's trying to change
the rules right now
i would say the people who want to go to
mass mail and ballots
but you understand why there is a
coronavirus pandemic
right and there are a lot of people uh
potentially if they waited long lines
uh when they go to the polls uh and they
could get they could get sick
especially older people or people with
underlying conditions
as a result a lot of people want to
change the rules so they don't have to
go way too long
well they don't have to touch all this
the appropriate way to deal with that is
number one arrangements at the polls
that protect people which can be done
now of course we have tried it we have
systems in place we're just doing more
of it this year because of a pandemic
it's the same ballots it's the same
processes
it's the same postal service unless of
course donald trump manages to kneecap
it
kneecap it and william barr gives a hint
about what this
this is really about william barr says
listen
this is a closely divided country and
what that
means is if too many people are able to
vote safely
it could be really bad for donald trump
that's the code that william barr
is using when he says listen we've got
to be careful this is a closely divided
country that's right
that's right and that's why the idea
from trump is
suppress the vote that we know will be
disproportionately a vote for joe biden
people taking coronavirus more seriously
are more likely to vote by mail
if you suppress vote by mail you're more
likely to suppress
more biden votes than you are trump
votes
so um here is wolf explaining
to william barr that you can't vote
twice
that it's illegal to try to do it
willfully it's illegal
despite donald trump's encouragements
which i'll get to momentarily take a
look at this
and then let them go vote and if the
system is as good as they say it is
then obviously they won't be able to
vote it sounds like he's cur
encouraging people to break the law and
try to vote twice
well i don't know exactly what he was
saying but it seems to me what he's
saying
is he's trying to make the point that uh
the ability to monitor this system is
is not good and if it was so good if you
tried to vote a second time you would be
caught
if you voted in person that would be
illegal if they did that if somebody
mailed in a ballot and then actually
showed up
to vote in person uh that would be
illegal i don't know what the law on the
particular state said you can't vote
twice
well i don't know what the law in the
particular state says and when that vote
becomes final any state that says you
can vote twice
well there's some you know maybe that
you can change your vote up to a
particular time i don't know what the
law is
i'm not going to offer it he was saying
tesla you know because he doesn't know
what he's saying why are you asking me
what he's saying
he doesn't believe in the mail in voting
you're the attorney general of the
united states
right well the little experiment that
william barr is talking about there
would be a crime
we've never seen anything like this the
attorney general says
he doesn't know what the law is about
voting
around the country but he's sure based
on
logic as he said to wolf blitzer that
foreign countries are going to try to
print and send in millions of ballots
what's going on is unprecedented this is
a red alert
not a rehearsal and next i want to get
to donald trump actually suggesting
suggesting that voters commit what in
north carolina
is a felony the president of the united
states
said yesterday in north carolina that
voters
should try to vote twice he actually
said
you should go out there in north
carolina
mail in a vote and then on election day
go
and try to vote now donald trump is
suggesting this as a sort of
test of our election system donald trump
has tried to make
the public believe that our voting
systems are so terrible
so antiquated so bogus that
people could easily get away with
mailing in a ballot
and then going and voting and then your
vote is counted twice
now if the systems are working correctly
i've explained this to you
if you have sent in a ballot and then
you go in to vote in person it will show
up
you've already voted we've already
received your ballot via
absentee if the opposite happens
imagine for a moment that you send in a
ballot via mail but it hasn't been
received on election day
you go in and vote on election day and
you're allowed to
and then the next day your mail-in
ballot is received
that ballot would not be counted because
you've already been checked off as
having voted now
of course in a country of 331 million
anything can happen and anecdotally
there are probably
some cases of double votes getting by
people
much like there are cases of voting
machines going wrong
and you press one person and it
accidentally you know or
because of manipulation as some would
say casts a ballot
for the other guy or gal it's a country
of 331 million people
but the idea that that's widespread and
the idea that that's a good way to win
an election
is absolutely laughable well it's also a
felony in north carolina
and here is donald trump encouraging
voters
to commit a crime take a look at this
well i they'll go out and they'll vote
and they're going to have to go and
check their vote by going to the poll
and voting that way because
uh if it tabulates then they won't be
able to do that
so let them send it in and let them go
vote
and if their system's as good as they
say it is then obviously they won't be
able to vote
if it isn't tabulated they'll be able to
vote so that's the way it is
but send in your ballots send them in
strong whether it's solicited or
unsolicited the absentees are fine we
have to work to get them you know it
means something
and you send them in but you go to vote
and if they haven't counted it you can
vote
so that's the way i view it so this is a
crime
this is a crime the the law actually
says
intentionally double voting is a crime
put aside the fact
that it really would not work unless
something goes wrong
as i as i mentioned earlier if you mail
it in
you wouldn't be allowed to get an
in-person ballot if you vote in person
and then a mail-in ballot comes in the
mail-in ballot would be considered
spoiled
but this is a felony in north carolina
and in an interview last year kim wyman
who's the secretary of state in
washington state where
they've been doing vote by mail for
years she said
that these double voting scenarios are
extremely rare she said quote we can
usually run a list of people who have
appeared to vote more than once
out of 3.5 million ballots in 2018 it
appears 100 people may have voted more
than once counties are checking
100 people out of 3.5 million
ballots and of course of those hundred
many of them
were were caught that this is the number
of people who tried to vote more than
once
and uh kim wyman added is it perfect no
is there rampant fraud no do people
sometimes make mistakes
yes now here's the kicker donald trump
is not only suggesting that
voters commit a crime because it is a
crime to willfully go
and and try to vote twice donald trump
committed a crime donald trump was in
north carolina
when he said this and in north carolina
it is a
felony for quote any person with intent
to commit a fraud
to register or vote at more than one
precinct or more than one time
or to induce another to do so
so voting more than once is against the
law
and is a felony in north carolina and
suggesting to other people that they do
it
is also a crime in north carolina
and voting more than once is also
illegal under federal law
and all of this is really focused around
doing one thing
cast doubt on election results in
advance
so that if it's close if it's not close
quite frankly no matter what the results
are
donald trump will be able to say i've
been telling you all along
i've been telling you all along it's
rigged rigged rigged
and that's exactly what he's doing trump
is committing crimes in front of cameras
in order to do it
and who knows how many of his supporters
are going to be induced to commit a
crime
based on what donald trump said
yesterday we have to end this
we we have to get this malignancy
out of the white house and he's going to
do anything he can think of announcing
the vaccine
uh suggesting people test the system
dissuading people from voting post
office
foreign meddling it's all in play
and we have to overwhelm the vote in
order to prevent it
you know that that's the way to do it at
this point eight weeks out
i know that it's the way to do it as
well we have a voicemail number that you
can call whenever you please
that number is two one nine to david p
here is a very interesting voicemail
weighing in
about donald trump's weaponization of
soup which we covered yesterday take a
listen to this
hey david um i just wanted to call in
because
i thought of a little theory that i want
to get your thoughts on yeah
so as you know like trump has recently
begun talks of like
the weaponization of soup in bag and
canned form
right and i think that might just be why
he was so concerned about the cupboards
being bare
when he got into office right because
you know like we were out of bullets
the cupboards were bare like we were
completely defenseless basically
yeah exactly like no no cans i i would
wager no
no bags of sue yeah this is interesting
you know donald trump has been using
this phrase that when he took over from
barack obama the cupboards were bare
and it's weird to talk about cupboards
but where do people
keep cans of soup they typically keep
them in cupboards and maybe what donald
trump meant was
that soup cans which he now has made
clear he considers weapons in that weird
rant yesterday
the cupboard had no cans of soup that
is absolutely crazy but it makes about
as much sense as everything else that
donald trump says so i'm glad you're
thinking uh
to to our viewer who called in we have a
great bonus show for you today nancy
pelosi has handed trump
a gift and i'm going to tell you what
that is hoboken
is going to be suing fossil fuel
companies over
flooding saying it is a climate change
issue
and i am going to give you the latest
updates on the census i had some
interactions recently with census
workers
safe ones wearing masks of course all of
those stories and more
on the bonus show get instant access to
the bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video